split was one of the coolest movie-going
experiences I've ever had when that
ending hit I just had chills the energy
in the theater was amazing during that
final scene but it wasn't until I went
back and rewatched it later that I truly
realized how brilliant it was there were
hints about the ending all throughout
the movie if you want to hear about all
of them then stick around to the end of
this video
I'd recommend watching my things you
missed and unbreakable first since I
will be referencing it both split and
unbreakable open with a birthday scene
and unbreakable
it was the birth of Elijah price and in
split Claire binoy celebrates her
birthday at the end of the party her dad
offers a ride to her classmate Casey
cook but he never quite makes it into
the car last week I described how David
Dunne and Elijah price are color-coded
with David being associated with Greene
and Elijah being purple the Horde has
their own color to yellow it can be seen
in Dennis's handkerchief Hedwig's jacket
the flowers placed around the holding
room and at the train station the
lighting and wall colors throughout the
area below maintenance as well as the
tiles above-ground at the zoo in the
poster for glass the colors for each
character are made clear there are 24
sets of titles in the opening and
closing credits of splits one for each
of the 24 identities of the Horde the
opening credits also have letters
connected by a vertical line in a way
that makes it look like two entries on a
time line just as this is the second
entry in the series the accompanying
music by West Dylan Thornton sounds like
distorted animal cries take a listen
[Music]
so the girls are kidnapped and put in
this holding room Claire and Marcia have
different ideas about how to get out
than Casey and the room is a vertically
split just like the title of a movie by
this power line to show the divided
vertical divisions of the frame are also
a technique used a lot in Alfred
Hitchcock's horror classic psycho M
night Shyamalan the director of split
lists Hitchcock has a huge influence
even released a 10 minute video on his
appreciation of Hitchcock's strangers on
a train there are other cycle references
and split but we'll get to them when we
get to them Casey tells Marcia to pee
herself when Dennis takes her out of the
room hoping to prevent Dennis from
forcing her to do something that she
doesn't want to do the fact that Dennis
is a germaphobe that works in her favor
but really that was just luck around
this time one of the other identities
Barry reaches out to their psychologist
dr. Fletcher she's got several other
emails on the screen just as the art
department of unbreakable had cameos in
the newspaper the crew of split makes
cameos in dr. Fletcher's email
Charles s Row is credited as a
miscellaneous crew member joannabee West
Dominic attends awright and John Rusk
reported the production department Mitch
Campbell Lucas Andre Jennifer Westerner
ed Mendes and Bob lowering all worked
visual effects skip leave sy and Brian
Baker Adam leach and Matthew Shapiro
were part of the post-production team
and Lisa Liberace is James McAvoy's
girlfriend one of the emails mentioned
Suzanne the French painter and we'll
come back to that later I love all these
movies with just disturbing pictures in
the background
anyway Barry comes to see dr. Fletcher
but it's not really Barry
dr. Fletcher asked if he's looking for
something but he's actually putting the
room back in order because it's really
Dennis the guy with OCD
imagine having a disorder within your
disorder maybe mr. glass can relate
I have something called osteogenesis
imperfecta it's a genetic disorder
dr. le staple and I'm a psychiatrist I
specialize in those individuals who
believe they are superheroes anyway the
supposed berry talks about making a
jacket with hand printed newspaper
headlines I know someone who happens to
have a collection of newspaper headlines
also in dr. Fletcher's office there's a
picture on the wall of what appears to
be a woman looking behind a shower
curtain this is one of those psycho
references I was talking about after
Dennis Lee is doctor Fletcher goes
through her patient files the only one
that's legible is this one on a mr.
Douglas Latrell and as far as I can tell
the name is not relevant but then dates
on the file ranged from July 2000 to
November 2000 November 2000 is when
unbreakable was released and most of the
movie is set within these dates for
example the encounter with the orange
man and unbreakable takes place just
before October 23rd mm she also hasn't
been labeled Universal offices you can
probably guess who produced this movie
[Music]
dr. fletcher visits an art gallery to
view this suzanne painting probably the
one she received the email about earlier
this piece is called the Baylor's would
it be too much of a stretch to relate
this to david dunn swimming pool
accident or fear of water if your answer
is yes that is too much of a stretch
than fine but there's no denying this
line from dr. Fletcher's associate Joe
was an intentional clue you think of
them like they're super naturally gifted
like like they have powers or something
Karen these are patients they have been
through trauma whoa that's a good one
I'm curious if any of you picked up on
that the first time through and at what
point did you actually realize this was
a sequel I tried to look for some more
clues in dr. Fletcher's notes on the
various identities but I couldn't really
make out anything I don't know if this
was supposed to be a joke on that whole
trope about doctors having bad
handwriting
but I can't read any of it so let's go
back to Casey and the girls
Kaycee awakes from a flashback and we
see her point of view which is sideways
when I talked about unbreakable I
examined it the right-side up versus
upside down shots in that movie so maybe
these sideways shots in splits are a
little bit of an in-between this is also
one of the first times we get a good
peek out of the holding room and there's
a container of barnum animal crackers
one of the earliest clues towards their
location being the Philadelphia Zoo took
forever get this place safe with that
the nosy bodies that work here fine and
out you can't get out here back at dr.
Fletcher's office we've got our em night
cameo in the form of this guy who helps
Dr Fletcher and review security footage
of Dennis deliberately trying to prove
that he's Barry by walking through the
trash when Patricia brings Casey and
Marcia into the kitchen you can briefly
see that they all have different cereal
preferences which I found to be an
interesting detail one of the things I
talked about an unbreakable is how we
always see Elijah through a glass
reflection to represent the fragile
nature of his disorder we see Elijah
through the reflection each time he's
introduced at a new age in splits we see
Dennis in the reflection of the
certificate just before he first
introduces himself to dr. Fletcher
there's another reflection scene later
on which I'll come back to but in this
conversation we find out that the twenty
fourth identity the Beast resides away
from the other 23 identities in a train
yard because Kevin the dad left on a
train when he was young presumably that
was Easter L 177 Casey convinces headway
to show her his room which in another
clue about them being under the zoo is
filled with animal posters and toys
additionally the song that he famously
dances to in his room is called frog
base by the artist currently known as
snails
[Music]
[Music]
and this is actually a pretty good
drawing of restaurant that's what that's
supposed to be Hedwig shows Casey the
walkie-talkie but he stole from Dennis
and Casey uses it to try to call for
help but the man on the other end just
thinks that it's his friend pulling his
leg and it shows him that he still has
the orange headphones when Casey
eventually does get out at the end of
the movie we do see him listening to
those orange headphones before he calls
the police but before any of that is a
very important flashback to where a
young Casey holds her abusive uncle at
gunpoint in a scene that's a very very
reminiscent of Joseph holding David at
gunpoint in unbreakable Rohit's
do what your luck this isn't funny just
what the hell are you doing is it loaded
Joseph did you load that gun Casey
Joseph I'm your uncle
no I am your father adopted Casey Joseph
put that gun down
and I am Telling You to put that made
that gun down right now I'm getting
upset I'm about to get very angry you
are about to be in big trouble could
kill me
these scenes take place at almost the
exact same point in both movies maybe
one day I'll do a side-by-side
comparison but that sounds like another
video dr. Fletcher's concerned leads her
to try to talk to the Horde at his home
so she pulls up in a taxi remember how
the Channel 4 News logo and unbreakable
was very reminiscent of the Fantastic
Four logo well the letter T in this taxi
cab service is also a reference to the
teen titans logo the pieces are all
coming together as Dennis visits the
train station to transform into the
Beast and it's an Amtrak train just like
east rail 177 KC explores the hoards
computer and this is where we see the
video diaries of each member one of them
is named Norma which completes the
trifecta of psycho references this one
referencing Norma Bates
at some point dr. fletcher realizes she
probably won't make it out alive but she
leaves a note for the captive girls to
find the note is written on a receipt
from Hagen Ball laboratories which is
not a thing but Emily Hagen bot is the
author of this superhero book so you
know how the rest goes Casey has her
confrontation with the Beast the Beast
sees that she too has gone through some
abuse and lets her live someone finds
her an escort from below the maintenance
area and the orange headphones guy calls
the police one of the most disturbing
things to me is that even after all that
Casey has been through she still doesn't
want to go back with her uncle at the
end that's how bad he is but there's one
more loose end that still hasn't been
tied up on my end I mentioned the
unbreakable reference where we see the
hoard in the reflection of dr.
Fletcher's office just like those Elijah
price scenes in the first movie the
final scene with the hoard goes all in
on this and includes the panning back
and forth camera movement as seen in
many of the scenes in unbreakable all
the while James Newton Howard
unbreakable soundtrack slowly
transitions in as we cut to the credits
and the iconic end credits scene and the
reveal of David Dunn I've gotten
goosebumps just thinking about it now
the stage is set for glass and I could
not be more excited so join me next week
as I break down everything you might
have missed in the conclusion to the
east rail one-77 trilogy remember to
subscribe
these world for new horrors every week
ring that death bound for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive